bonjour George Sérignac merci beaucoup
d'être notre invité ce matin vous êtes
le grand maître du Grand Orient de
France c'est la principale obédience
maçonnique et le grand Orion qui fête
ses 250 ans en cette année être
franc-maçon en 2023 qu'est-ce que ça
signifie
alors
bonjour Merci de merci de nous recevoir
être franc-maçon en 2023 ça signifie en
tout cas au Grand Orient de France être
profondément encore non seulement
imprégnée des valeurs de la République
des principes de la République mais
aussi être
convaincu de l'importance aujourd'hui de
la défendre et de la préserver voir de
la sauvegarder c'est donc bien sûr avec
une méthode particulière
héritée d'une tradition depuis près de
trois siècles
une singularité mais aussi depuis la
seconde moitié du 19e siècle un
engagement pour la République qui
dans le rôle historique est démontré par
les archives qui sont totalement publics
tout de suite pour déminer démystifier
le fameux secret maçonnique et donc cet
engagement républicain pour le pour la
construction d'abord de la République
dans la seconde moitié du 19e siècle et
ensuite pour la préserver et faire
avancer aussi la société mais toujours
dans l'idée des principes républicains
faire que cette société
aboutisse finalement à la République
telle qu'elle a été conçue à partir de
la Révolution française
la franc-maçonnerie à la réputation
d'être très secrète d'agir dans l'ombre
d'avoir ces codes vous exprimez dans les
médias vous faites même un tour de
France en ce moment est-ce que vous
estimez qu'il faut un peu casser cette
image et qu'il vous faut parler au plus
grand nombre
alors c'est oui en quelque sorte oui
mais cette image c'est une un déficit
finalement de la communication de la
franc-maçonnerie au sens moderne nous
avons une méthode qui est la discrétion
c'est comme ça les francs-maçons ne
surréagissent pas l'actualité ils
travaillent sur le temps long il
travaille sur la philosophie les grands
principes évidemment donc cette méthode
ne peut pas aller avec une communication
à tout craint où nous surréagirions à
l'actualité où nous serions
régulièrement tel un parti politique ou
un syndicat ce qui est très important
les partis politiques et syndicats mais
c'est pas vous mais c'est pas nous voilà
donc en revanche
la présentation qui est faite de la
maçonnerie est une présentation fausse
l'image de la maçonnerie dans le grand
public pour pour beaucoup et est
mauvaise c'est à dire que l'idée
maçonnique est une idée généreuse est
une idée de construire une société de
solidarité de justice notre devise c'est
liberté égalité fraternité qui est à peu
près équivalente en date à celle de
l'adoption par la République et donc
notre communication aujourd'hui n'est
pas du tout de revenir sur notre
discrétion et notre façon de travailler
pas du tout
mais en revanche d'expliciter mieux ce
qu'est l'idée maçonnique mais est-ce que
pour ça il faut pas une plus grande
ouverture une plus grande transparence
sur la franc-maçonnerie alors ça dépend
ce qu'on appelle transparence
là le si vous voulez le fait que nous
réunions ce que nous appelons nos tenues
soit uniquement réservé à ceux qui sont
franc-maçons c'est simplement ce qu'on
appelle le secret des délibérations
c'est à dire ce qui se pratique
finalement dans beaucoup d'associations
qui ne reçoivent que leur propre membre
quand elle travaille voire des grands
corps d'état où on fait le serment de
garder le secret des délibérations et
c'est pas le secret maçonnique dont tout
le monde parle avec beaucoup de beaucoup
de fantasmes finalement mais ça c'est
quelque chose qui a été colportée par
les adversaires de la franc-maçonnerie
c'est-à-dire que dès le début ceux qui
trouvaient que la maçonnerie allait les
gêner c'est l'ancien régime en fait la
monarchie absolue de droit divin soutenu
par
papoter et cela qui sont les adversaires
de la maçonnerie identifient la
maçonnerie quand même un danger pour
leur pouvoir leur pouvoir temporel bien
sûr et à partir de là commence à
répandre sur la maçonnerie cette image
très sulfureuse mais comment on devient
franc-maçon aujourd'hui alors très très
simplement d'abord pour nous je parle du
grand-mât du Grand Orient de France
parce que voilà je n'ai
pas et donc au Grand Orient de France il
suffit de alors soit de connaître un
franc-maçon qui vous le propose bien sûr
soit d'écrire 16 rue cadets au siège du
Grand Orient de France vous écrivez
voilà mais ensuite il faut montrer qu'on
a une véritable ce que je disais au tout
début de notre entretien qu'on a une
véritable adhésion mais profonde aux
valeurs républicaines pour nous c'est
absolument essentiel d'avoir cette cet
engagement cet engagement pour les
valeurs républicaines justement on va en
parler des valeurs républicaines parce
que chaque siècle a connu son grand
combat il y a eu l'égalité au 18e siècle
le progrès social au 19e la laïcité
enfin 19e début 20e c'est quoi
aujourd'hui le combat majeur pour vous
du XXe siècle
on est dans une période où je dirais il
y a il faut mettre plusieurs il y a
plusieurs éléments parce que on est dans
une période très particulière de de
l'histoire même de l'humanité donc il y
a des il y a des combats majeurs à très
court terme par exemple le combat
politique contre l'extrême droite qui
pour nous est très important puisque
nous nous décernons pas de de brevet de
partie qui appartiennent à la République
ou pas c'est pas notre notre sujet nous
travaillons sur les grands principes et
nous craignons tout ce qui peut
atteindre la République et donc à partir
de là tout ce qui ressemblerait d'une
dérive démocratique républicaine parce
que on ne peut confondre pas rép ublique
et démocratie ce qui est important pour
nous c'est la République démocratie
démocratique c'est-à-dire que le terme
de République est au moins aussi
important que le terme démocratique dans
la république démocratique et donc dans
Ça c'est le combat à court terme c'est à
dire
rassemblement national oui bien sûr
évidemment et mais pas seulement
également par d'autres qui se sont
présentés à l'extrême droite que nous
nous conseillons si vous voulez nous
avons pour simplifier les choses dans
notre règlement général nous avons un
article qui dit on ne peut pas
appartenir au Grand Orient de France si
on tient des propos on appartient à un
groupement raciste xénophobe prenant la
haine de l'autre ça c'est dans notre
règlement général c'est donc dans notre
statut je dirais dans notre ADN voilà ce
qui définit notre position le
rassemblement national son président
Marine Le Pen
oui bien sûr mais son entourage sans
défend moins on va dire
oui contre les totalitarismes pas
seulement c'est là vraiment la défense
de la République nous n'avons nous
n'avons pas de combat contre quiconque
nous cherchons à préserver à sauvegarder
la République c'est ça qui est très
important et surtout aussi à la faire
encore progresser pour aboutir par
exemple dans le combat dans aujourd'hui
il y a un sujet parce que vous parlez
des sujets c'est pas un combat majeur
mais c'est un sujet très important pour
nous c'est celui de la fin de vie celui
de l'Etat nazie mais si vous voulez oui
on va en parler mais juste pour finir
sur le rassemblement national est-ce que
pour vous la montée du rassemblement
national dans le pays est inéluctable
alors je pense qu'il faut faire du
catastrophisme éclairé c'est à dire que
il faut voir les choses telles qu'elles
sont c'est-à-dire qu'aujourd'hui le
rassemblement national a un comportement
irréprochable à l'Assemblée nationale
comme vous dites les propos de Marine Le
Pen sont parfaitement républicains et
sont dans le débat dans le débat
démocratique parfaitement recevable donc
dans cette dans cette conjoncture on
peut imaginer qu'il accède au pouvoir
effectivement aux prochaines échéances
et les sondages s'ils sont révélateurs
montrent quand même une évolution très
nette au fil des années depuis depuis 10
ans on va dire de la monter Marine Le
Pen qui prend vraiment une stature
présidentielle donc à partir de là
l'idée c'est de de d'expliquer en fait
quel est le programme quels sont les
choses enfin moi j'ai pas de conseil à
donner aux politiques parce que c'est
pas c'est pas mon objet mais nous en
tout cas dans nos loges dans nos
ateliers ce qui se travaille c'est
plutôt sur le fond des choses c'est et
parce que nous pensons que l'électorat
lui
n'est pas vraiment ne mesure pas le
geste qu'il fait en votant pour des des
programmes d'extrême droite parce
difficile la stratégie des diabolisation
et aussi parce qu'il y a une faiblesse
des autres partis politiques c'est ça
qui explique pour vous la montée du
rassemblement national si vous voulez
qui est une
disparition des autres partis politiques
c'est certain c'est une observation que
tout le monde fait y compris au sein des
partis politiques bien sûr donc et ça
c'est très très troublant pour notre
notre débat démocratique parce que la
vitalité du débat démocratique elle est
représentée par la vigueur des partis
politiques bien sûr mais à partir de là
bon voilà il y avait sûrement d'autres
facteurs il y a des facteurs très
nombreux des facteurs culturels je
parlais de la période très particulière
que nous vivions parce que dans les
combats importants il y a aussi bien sûr
le problème de même du futur de
l'humanité avec l'écologie avec le
dérèglement climatique et la chute
drastique de la biodiversité qui sont
des problèmes qu'aujourd'hui dont nous
saisissons dans nos loges
la méthode maçonnique c'est de
travailler sur les idées nous sommes la
MA
la société et qui probablement si
l'écologie ne conduit pas à un désastre
dans les années qui viennent les
historiens futurs verront notre époque
probablement avec cette révolution
sociétale tout à fait majeur comme
essentiel vous nous le dites le but de
votre but c'est de produire des idées
vous avez un combat politique mais vous
n'êtes pas un parti politique l'âge d'or
de la franc-maçonnerie en termes
d'influence politique c'était la
troisième République la franc-maçonnerie
aujourd'hui est-ce qu'elle a encore une
influence politique alors moi je fais
partie des peut-être des rares qui je
pense que ça n'est pas l'âge d'or de
l'influence de la franc-maçonnerie la
Troisième République c'est l'âge d'or de
la visibilité en politique de la
franc-maçonnerie parce que on est dans
le combat républicain on est dans l'acné
du combat républicain contre la
monarchie et à ce moment là comme la
franc-maçonnerie s'est engagée dans ce
combat républicain beaucoup d'hommes
profondément imprégnés des valeurs
républicaines et qui vont avoir un
engagement très fort sont aussi
franc-maçons et on le sait donc c'est
une visibilité mais l'influence de la MA
théorie comme je vous l'ai dit ce sont
les frères et les sœurs qui travaillent
dans l'humilité dans le l'obscurité même
des temples dans le silence et qui peut
à peu dans leur vie familiale
professionnelle associatif syndicale
parfois politique diffuse ces idées et
aujourd'hui nous sommes relativement
nombreux puisque le Grand Orient de
France compte environ 54000 membres nous
avons près de 1400 loges 1400 ateliers
et donc cette diffusion généralisée sur
tout le territoire voir à l'étranger
aussi permet simplement cette diffusion
des idées bien loin de la caricature
colportée de grands maîtres ou de
franc-maçons qui manipuleraient qui
serait des marionnettesistes du monde ce
qui est grotesque alors sans être
stupide mais est-ce que vous avez une
influence au Parlement puisqu'on est sur
une chaîne parlementaire est-ce que vous
avez une influence dans le vote des lois
alors je crois que c'est toujours dans
le même registre c'est-à-dire dans
l'évolution des idées c'est à dire que
on il est évident qu'il y a aujourd'hui
encore des francs-maçons parlementaires
bien sûr parlementaire il a une vie
personnelle et il savait dans quel
proportion non non on ne voulait on n'a
pas de fichage c'est ça va pas très bien
le fichage avec les francs-maçons donc
on préfère éviter ça mais en revanche on
sait c'est qu'il y a des francs-maçons
parlementaires bien sûr mais que chacun
vote en fonction de ses convictions
politiques alors évidemment républicaine
bien sûr enfin en tout cas nous le
souhaitons bien que les textes qui sont
discutés au Parlement font l'objet de
débat en loge alors si vous voulez par
exemple concernant la loi sur la fin de
vie future qui sera peut-être mise au
programme de de nos parlementaires bien
sûr que par exemple ça fait partie si
vous voulez en loge
il y a la liberté de choix de chaque
loge voire de chaque frère et soeur de
présenter un sujet et évidemment qu'à
partir du moment tout ce que je vous ai
touche que je vous ai dit bien sûr que
tout est discuté en loge tout est dans
la liberté et la liberté et la
souveraineté des loges et pour nous très
importantes au contrôle de France et
donc cette liberté de parole qui est
aussi une des grands un des grands
apports de la franc-maçonnerie au 18e
siècle qui est méconnue c'est cette
liberté de parole qui n'existait pas à
cette époque là sur la fin de vie est-ce
que vos discussions sont allées au-delà
de la loge on sait que le gouvernement
consulte consulte largement pour
préparer ce texte est-ce que vous avez
été consulté oui bien sûr consultez
comme d'ailleurs je crois le
gouvernement l'a fait pour de nombreux
courants de pensée ce qui est très bien
ce qui est normal je crois que c'est une
c'est quelque chose de tellement
important qui interpelle vraiment la
conscience au plus profond de chacune et
chacun d'entre nous donc oui nous avons
été consultés nous avons
été consulté bien sûr mais également par
la Convention citoyenne au Conseil
économique et social par la commission
parlementaire présidée par donc nous
avons été consultés avec avec d'autres
obédiences maçonniques avec d'autres
courants de pensées nous avons exposé
nos arguments voilà
notre position elle est très claire elle
est elle est travaillée elle est
argumentée comme je vous l'ai dit depuis
longtemps alors pour pour faire vite
parce que c'est un sujet complexe qui
interpelle vraiment la conscience nous
sommes pour aller plus loin dans la
possibilité que chaque être humain et le
droit de disposer de sa vie bien sûr
mais aussi de sa mort et donc ce droit
nouveau qui n'enlève à personne un droit
ancien puisque ceux qui ne veulent pas
disposer de cette possibilité d'abréger
leur souffrance par exemple ou d'en
finir parce que on est en fin de vie
n'enlève rien ceux qui ne veulent pas de
ce droit pour des raisons religieuses
par exemple ou pour de raisons certains
vous savez comme Pascal disait qu'on
accède à la spiritualité par la
souffrance très bien nous respectons
parfaitement cela mais en revanche ceux
qui ont une maladie dégénérative ou ceux
qui souffrent pour d'autres raisons qui
sont en fin de vie qui sont pas là qui
ne veulent pas d'acharnement de ce qu'on
appelle l'acharnement thérapeutique par
exemple qui sont encore en pleine
conscience avec toutes les protections
de la loi parce que la loi doit protéger
et libérer c'est la fonction de la loi
elle doit protéger libérer nous sommes
évidemment pour ajouter ce droit à la
République parce que pour nous et notre
c'est notre argument c'est vraiment un
droit républicain mais aller plus loin
c'est aller jusqu'au est-ce qu'il faut
aller jusqu'à légaliser l'euthanasie
alors c'est toujours pareil on peut pas
parler à coup de slogans légaliser
l'euthanasie c'est quelque chose qui qui
qui est très brutal comme ça parce que
ça serait la porte ouverte
ça serait nous nous essayons d'apporter
de la nuance au débat public c'est à
dire que je je crois que ce qu'il faut
cette particulièrement précautionneux
dans la rédaction d'une telle loi il
faut protéger les patients bien sûr de
tout du moins de rabbus quel qu'il soit
il faut protéger les soignants aussi de
qui c'est une responsabilité terrible
qui est qui sont et je crois qu'il faut
prendre exemple peut-être sur la
Belgique sur d'autres sur des pays qui
ont déjà avancé mais surtout faire un
travail législatif d'horlogerie de
joaillerie dans la rédaction d'un tel
texte qui est tout à fait essentiel je
crois pour la liberté de conscience pour
respecter la liberté de consciente qui
est quand même la clé de voûte de notre
République la loi 1905 la République
c'est pour ça que la République
issue des principes de la révolution
française de la Constitution de 1793
cette république là elle elle doit
avancer dans l'amélioration et
l'extension des droits au sens le plus
républicain du terme on parlait de la
loi de 1905 on va parler justement du
lien est-ce qu'il y a un lien entre
franc-maçonnerie et religion
c'est une question qui me désarçonne un
petit peu
si vous voulez la franc-maçonnerie nous
avons adopté au Grand Orient de France
en 1877 comme principe cardinal la
liberté absolue de conscience donc nous
avons quand on est en France des
croyants
pratiquant ou non mais aussi des
non-croyants agnostiques athées qui ont
la spirituel la spiritualité l'option
spirituelle qu'il choisisse et donc ben
voilà la religion est une affaire intime
que nous respectons parfaitement bien
sûr au Grand Orient de France puisque
c'est la liberté absolue cardinal et qui
définit depuis 1877 même vraiment notre
franc-maçonnerie donc voilà voilà les
liens que nous avons avec la religion
est-ce que pour vous aujourd'hui la
laïcité dans notre pays est en danger
oui bien sûr bien sûr il y a deux
présentations si vous voulez et c'est
encore un débat profondément républicain
il y a deux options alors je parle pas
de tout ce qui n'est pas démocratie dans
le monde mais il y a deux modèles qui
est le modèle républicain c'est-à-dire
laïque à la française telle que nous
nous vivons avec eux et puis il y a le
modèle anglo-saxon qui n'est pas un
modèle républicain même s'il y a des
républicains on voyait qui est un modèle
plutôt de démocratie à l'anglo-saxonne
avec une vision de la sécularisation
qui est différente de la nôtre qui est
donc notre laïcité et donc dans notre
modèle aujourd'hui républicain
bien sûr que cette ce modèle est menacé
tous les jours tous les jours il est
menacé évidemment ce qui apparaît en
premier lieu c'est c'est l'islam
politique qui régulièrement fait une
offensive depuis depuis une trentaine
d'années on va dire c'est apparu en 89
avec le l'affaire du voile de Creil on
voit bien
je ne sais pas si le gagne de plus en
plus de terrain il faudrait vous savez
c'est très difficile à apprécier parce
qu'il y a l'effet de loupe il y a les
médias il y a l'instrumentalisation
politique de part et d'autre donc c'est
très difficile à savoir mais vous savez
peggiser
il faut dire ce que l'on voit et surtout
il faut voir ce que l'on voit donc il ne
sert à rien de se masquer je trouve que
cette phrase est tout à fait
intéressante à appliquer de nos jours
parce que
chacun chacune chacun d'entre nous mais
aussi les médias mais aussi les
politiques distillent ce qu'il voit ou
voit-il ce qu'il voit je trouve que
c'est
aujourd'hui sur la montée de l'islam
politique sur cette question de la
laïcité je pense que c'est aussi bien du
côté des politiques que du côté des
Français peut-être c'est un sujet
inflammable bien sûr on le voit bien
c'est un sujet qui est source de tension
terrible on ne peut pas nier aujourd'hui
qu'il y a nos concitoyens de religion
d'origine musulmane qui ont la plénitude
de leurs droits et que nous évidemment
en plus nous franc-maçons républicain
respectons on n'a pas les respecter
d'ailleurs ils font partie de la
communauté ce sont des citoyens comme
nous parfaitement à égalité de droit et
voilà le respect mutuel est presque
structurel donc c'est pas un sujet à la
pour nous le respect de de de
concitoyens quel que soit son origine sa
religion son il n'y a que des Français
de de voilà
exactement la communauté républicaine
qui pour nous est essentielle donc à
partir de là mais on ne peut pas nier
non plus que le problème qu'a rencontré
notre pays il y a un siècle et demi
enfin jusqu'à il y a un siècle et demi
avec la religion catholique pas dans le
dans son aspect religieux mais son don
de l'aspect temporel application à la
Société des préceptes de la religion
existent aujourd'hui avec la religion
musulmane qui qui est dans son identité
chacune et chacun de nos concitoyens
d'origine musulmanes à plus de de
ressenti de l'importance sur la société
elle-même sur le fonctionnement de la
société de la religion qui est un nouvel
une nouvelle version du clericanisme que
la République refuse que la République
laïque combat et donc voilà donc c'est
un sujet très important
de la laïcité et c'est un lien avec une
actualité forte au Sénat c'est la
question du fond Marianne il y a une
commission d'enquête sénatoriale sur
l'attribution de ce fond Marianne se
font il a été créé à la suite de la mort
de Samuel Paty pour lutter contre le
séparatisme est-ce que les doutes qu'il
y a sur l'attribution de ce fond sur son
utilité même sa nuit pour vous à la
lutte contre le séparatisme alors je
vais vous répondre sans essayer de faire
sans faire de langue en essayant de ne
pas faire de quoi la première chose
c'est que comme je vous l'ai dit nous ne
sommes pas un parti politique ni qui
soutiendrait une majorité ou telle
partie ou telle partie le moins au Grand
Orient de France il y a des gens plutôt
de droite plutôt de gauche du centre il
y a de tout donc moi je représente les
membres de mon home audience l'éloge
donc il n'est pas question de de porter
le moindre jugement en plus sur une
affaire qui n'est pour l'instant que
médiatique
pour l'instant
elle n'était que judiciaire on en
entendrait même pas parler puisque c'est
a priori le secret de l'instruction donc
à partir de là il n'est pas question de
porter le moindre jugement ni positif ni
négatif là-dessus en revanche que cette
affaire médiatique justement sur quelque
chose d'aussi important qui intervient
après le crime abominable l'assassinat
Samuel Paty a qui nous avions remis de à
titre posthume d'ailleurs le prix du
Grand Orient de France il y a deux ans
et c'était la sœur de Samuel Paty qui
était venue Michael Patty donc nous
avons commémoré d'ailleurs ce triste
anniversaire l'année dernière devant le
collège de Samuel Paty donc cette
affaire là qui est particulièrement
sensible qui devrait être exemplaire
même le ce fond Marianne évidemment que
nous sommes très affectés et nous
souhaitons vraiment que que tout ça ne
soit qu'un soufflé
et qui qui retombe nous le souhaitons
ardemment parce que tous ceux qui peut
affaiblir le combat républicain et pour
nous terriblement dommageable c'est
c'est tout notre combat bien sûr merci
beaucoup merci Georges Sérignac merci
d'avoir été notre invité ce matin on va
continuer à parler de ces sujets tout de
suite dans le club des territoires